i am constantly getting fundraising
emails from donald trump
sometimes i'll get 10 in a day my gmail
has started redirecting them
immediately to spam but i still check
that folder and see them in there
and some of these fundraising emails
from the trump campaign
have seemed more and more panicked more
and more desperate
but it turns out based on multiple new
reports
that donald trump's campaign is having a
financial problem they have had to cut
ads that they are running
they have spent almost 75 percent of all
the money they raised this entire
election cycle
and in thinking about this you all know
that i hate
how our american politics depends on
money and depends on fundraising
i think the system is corrupt i think
the system is corrosive i think it must
be changed
it just so happens that this is the
system we have right now
and it just so happens that this could
be a real problem for donald trump
in the last couple of months before the
election according to the new york times
donald trump has largely stopped
advertising on tv
as joe biden is spending more and more
on television particularly in key
states that could be the deciding states
uh with
the more than 360 million dollars that
joe biden raised in august
which is a record and i'll get to that
in a moment the new york times
goes on to say quote the trump campaign
is expected to increase television
spending next week
but several republicans said that bill
stephen trump's campaign manager since
july
was taking a cautious approach after the
former leadership
spent huge sums on television and
digital ads
earlier this year to no discernible
effect
the light television spending and
advertising blackouts in some key states
have mystified allies raising questions
about how much cash
the campaign has in the bank now if you
just look at the top line
you might not be that alarmed for
example you might hear
that trump raised 1.1 billion dollars
and that is true
but that goes back to the start of 2019
and they didn't spend that money on the
primary
uh and that should be an advantage
because joe biden did have to spend
money on the primary but somehow
73 of the 1.1 billion
that has been raised has already been
spent almost identical
to donald trump's business and personal
lives they are spending on stupid things
going back to the new york times quote
the campaign assembled a big and
well-paid staff
and housed the team at a cavernous
well-appointed office in the virginia
suburbs
outsized legal bills were treated as
campaign costs
and more than 100 million dollars was
spent on a television advertising blitz
before the party convention
the point when most of the electorate
historically begins
to play co pay close attention to the
race
so trump having money problems on the
other side of this
joe biden is raising record amounts of
money 365
million dollars raised in august
choosing kamala harris caused a spike
in fundraising and yes biden
has saved a ton of money by campaigning
remotely for a lot of the pandemic being
able to save up money for the tv blitz
that they are now doing and you know
trump
donald trump jr and others like to laugh
at joe biden's
zoom fundraisers those have been major
successes
those zoom fundraisers shockingly
have kept costs down and sometimes bring
in nearly three-quarters of a million
dollars in 90 minutes so
big picture is this shocking no
this is what happens when listen we know
that trump was using campaign funds for
paying legal bills
we know that trump was using campaign
funds to pay his own family lara trump
pulling a couple hundred grand
uh you know all these different trump
kids and family members getting paid
and i want to remind you that there was
this idea that trump was so wealthy
wealthy that he would self-fund his
campaign he wouldn't even need to
fundraise because he's a
multi-billionaire
in fact not only is he fundraising and
spending all of that money he is now
struggling
to fundraise and uh there are of course
questions about whether money has been
used illegally
the answer is probably yes in reality it
will likely have no repercussions
whatsoever
um the uh last thought on this
i uh i want to go back to this i'm not
telling you this
because i think it's great that we have
a system where the person
i am telling you this because if we're
going to evaluate the campaign
attached to reality we can't ignore
that fundraising is a big signal about
voter enthusiasm and the fact that
donald trump appears to be
so short on cash is not particularly
good for him now later on in the program
we're going to look at polling today
compared to polling on this day four
years ago
and what i told you two to three weeks
ago about how the polling this year
compared to hillary's polling in august
of 2016
that has changed significantly and we're
going to look at that next
remember that this program is available
every day
in its long form audio format for free
on any of your favorite podcasting
platforms if you're an itunes gal
if you're a spotify bro if you're a
pandora kid whatever
make sure you get the daily long form
audio podcast
and let me know what you think about the
state of the campaign
in your state by sending me a tweet
i am deep hackman on twitter
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor
i'm thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress at home
and it's just the perfect mattress one
of the best things about helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have
and they will pair you with a mattress
that will be perfect for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed i
often get too hot at night
the mattress keeps me cool it's not too
soft it's not too firm the texture is
right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10-year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video